Oppenheimer is an intense story so of
course behind the scenes is no Cakewalk
there is not a single ounce of CGI used
yep that's right that explosive scene
actually very explosive Christopher
Nolan wrote the script in a way that's
never been done before and they actually
shot scenes in the real oppenheimer's
house so we have a lot to unpack here
Killian Murphy did a major Deep dive
into Oppenheimer in order to play his
titular role luckily because he's a
major historical figure there are a ton
of Articles books and documentaries for
him to devour he describes his method of
getting into character as going from the
outside in well you know we really
wanted to get silhouette right in the
voice right and the physicality right he
worked very closely with the hair makeup
and costume Department as well as
Christopher Nolan to make sure the
character he depicted on the screen was
the one they both wanted oppenheimer's
character as well as the entire film is
basically a collaborative process
between Christopher Nolan and Killian
Murphy two of them together watching
them build this character
it's why the whole movie works yeah
Christopher Nolan knew that Killian
Murphy's role as Oppenheimer was going
to be the centerpiece of the time but he
also knew that he needed to have the
most extraordinary Ensemble of people
around him for the movie to be a success
Fields feel every single character is
significant because they're all
historical figures of consequence Matt
Damon plays Leslie Groves a lieutenant
general in the United States Army who
worked right beside Oppenheimer and
pushed everything through on the
military side of things in order to
create this nuclear weapon he played a
major part in the making of Batman and
little boy and using them against
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945. so yeah
this is definitely a pretty heavy role
Matt Damon wanted to familiarize himself
with Leslie Grove's history before
taking on the challenge of bringing the
role to life on screen he Compares
playing Groves as almost like being a
kindergarten teacher it's because these
scientists were so eccentric and not
necessarily trustworthy okay let's talk
about that nuke scene surprisingly it's
100 real I mean okay they didn't
actually create a nuclear weapon but it
seems like it kind of felt like it to
everyone else on set that day they shot
that scene last because they knew they
were going to have to learn how to
utilize technology in a way they never
had before it was actually so intense to
shoot that they know for a fact this
couldn't have been done 10 years ago it
was definitely a sight to see a lot of
the actors and crew members were dizzy
from the explosives but Christopher
Nolan was hilariously unfazed it was
Chris just kind of calmly looked over at
nilo and I Chris because it was good
you can probably gather from how real
the nuke scene was that there's pretty
much no CGI in this entire movie some
things might have been subtly enhanced
with VFX but otherwise they relied
heavily on practical effects my
preference is to always do things in
camera as much as possible so it's a
major challenge for every department on
set but if it can be done practically in
a Christopher Nolan film that's the way
it will be done which brings me to my
next Point nothing in this film was
built on a Backlot everything was deeply
researched to be built with the utmost
authenticity in real locations the more
things can just be real the better
they're going to feel to the audience
they even built the Los Alamos Ranch on
the same mountain range that the real
one sits on we built all of these
buildings 360. we want it to feel like
you are right there no detail was
overlooked when it came to Bringing
reality into this movie they even shot
in a lot of real locations like
Princeton and oppenheimer's actual house
there are a lot of black and white shots
in this movie but it's also shot for
IMAX every crew member on this film has
to adjust their work for the iMac screen
iMacs can contain 18K resolution per
frame and when it came to shooting
scenes in black and white a 65
millimeter black and white format just
didn't exist so obviously they had to
engineer it they literally created the
black and white film that they were
using to shoot the movie they had to
test it through the filming process and
put it up on the iMac screen seeing it
at the end of the production was this
huge jaw-dropping gas inducing moment
for the cast and crew just to know that
they created something new and so
absolutely stunning for the iMac screen
was pretty groundbreaking I'd definitely
be putting that on my resume one thing
about movie scripts they're not written
in first person except for this one this
might be the only screenplay in history
ever written like this in Hollywood
don't quote me on it but feel free to
look it up and let me know in the
comments it made it clear to anyone who
wrote script that we're on this ride
with Oppenheimer Christopher Nolan wrote
it this way so everyone could really
feel how Oppenheimer felt through every
step of his journey and also understand
just how traumatic everything was for
him as well Chris wanted the audience
and the reader right there on his
shoulder The Narrative of the objective
is essentially told through Louis
Straw's character which is just a
completely unconventional way to write a
screenplay and I'm absolutely here for
it Christopher Nolan took this film to a
completely new level with the attention
to detail of character development the
hyper-realistic sets and the insane
amount of explosives it took for the
nuke scene to be almost too real what is
your favorite behind the scenes moment